comic book call backs a subtle nod to
friendship and hidden messages to mom
every superhero needs a good costume and
you won't believe the secrets inside
these mcu ensembles no
no i don't think i will the hulk is
known for his iconic purple pants but
when hulk was introduced they were
actually blue it wasn't until 1962's
incredible hulk issue 4 that he earned
his barney tinted trousers it's not like
purple pants grow on trees there's only
one dillards that carries these it's all
the way downtown and now i have to
many depictions of the character in
popular culture since have had him
wearing the purple pants likely because
the color contrasts against his green
skin so well but marvel films have
largely shied away from having bruce
banner wearing lavender coloured
trousers nevertheless like wolverine's
x-men outfit luke cage's headband or
visions green and yellow marvel has been
open to making wink-wink jokes about the
garish colors that looks so good on the
splash page but not on a cinema screen
in 2008 the incredible hulk bruce and
betty ross are reunited and on the run
from thunderbolt ross when betty buys
some clothes for him
what it's a quick call back to the
characters comic book roots just enough
to put a smile on the faces of knowing
fans
scott lang slash ant-man and hope van
dyne wasp spent the second ant-man film
fighting avastar ghost with the film
being hope's formal introduction as a
hero ant-man and wasp are both obviously
named after insects and can shrink to
their size for super aerobic battling
alluded to by the costume department
crafting of their suits the head of a
wasp can be seen on hope's suit while
the head of an ant has depicted in scots
duds both insects even have visible
antennae making them both fun and
surprisingly accurate though some might
not take notice of what appears to be
typical superhero costume paneling both
suits shift to a different shape after
the pinch of portions making the details
clearly intentional it's a subtle
callback to the insects these heroes are
named after and as always one of those
things that once you become aware you'll
never be able to not see it
the first marvel disney plus series one
division was not only a lot of fun but
also subject to perhaps the highest
degree of fan dissection one moments i
really had fans talking was the
halloween costumes of wonder maximoff
scarlet witch and vision are you old red
riding hood
i'm a sokovian fortune teller
when wonder and vision showed off the
halloween costumes an all-new halloween
spooktacular sharp-eyed viewers
recognized the nods to their traditional
comic book appearance years before one
division became a reality elizabeth
olsen said on late night with seth
meyers that when she was cast she was
told she'd never have to wear the comic
book suit you know i i did ballet
growing up but that's not a confident
look in a 2021 interview with looper
however producer mary lovanos said olsen
was excited about the chance to include
the costume in the series in addition to
wonder and vision wearing their comic
book suits ralph boner pietro war quick
silver's comic book look wonder
envisions children in the sitcom
universe billy and tommy could also be
seen wearing halloween costumes alluding
to their comic book roots the inclusion
of all five comic book looks as
halloween costumes was a whimsical
thrill a nod to the source material and
perhaps a microcosm of the entire series
unique tone
in 2017 store ragnarok hulk bruce banner
learned some crucial info about where
he's been and what's been going on in
his life since he left the avengers at
the end of avengers age of ultron if he
wanted to know more about himself
however perhaps all he had to do was
look down in one scene bruce is wearing
what appears to be a duran duran shirt
remember he'd been forced to put on tony
stark's clothes after reverting to human
form put these on this is a tony's club
not only is a tea and sport coat combo
something less than zero era downey jr
would have worn but the shirt bears
artwork from the band's 1982 album rio
which produced the classic hungry like
the wolf at first it feels like a
throwaway bit of character development
that stark just happens to be a lover of
early 80s british new wave but the
t-shirt actually isn't truly dranjaran
related it just bears the same patrick
nagel artwork used on the album what's
the connection you might recall that
later in the film hulk has a key
smackdown with fenris a massive wolf who
runs alongside the evil heller some
marvel fans have concluded that the
stark shirt foreshadows that
confrontation but not so fast according
to ruffalo himself he was allowed to
select the robert downey jr referencing
wardrobe and the t is a reference to his
real life friend not a ragnarok plot
point in an interview to promote the
film ruffalo said i picked the things i
thought would be the most like downey jr
he loves duran duran they played at his
birthday party so i was like oh my god i
have to get the duran duran logo but i
couldn't get it so i got the nagel
instead
wonder vision and hulk are the only ones
who have been glimpsed in their comic
book looks at some point in the mcu in
2019's captain marvel carol danvers got
a similar shouts out to her comic book
look when carol asked monica rambo for
help deciding what color she should wear
several different designs are cycled
through before the duo decide on the
iconic red and blue suit the fun comes
in with three projected color
combinations spotted by eagle-eyed fans
definitely not the first is an all-red
version of the suit a cool bag to the
red miss marvel comic book outfit the
next attempt is black and gold
reminiscent of a miss marvel suit
moniker then changes the suit colours to
a green and grey ensemble reminiscent of
the marvel suit in the comics
mcu easter eggs don't have to reference
old comic books sometimes they call back
to beloved plot points from the other
films in the pages of marvel comics
there was a romantic relationship
between black widow slash natasha
romanov and hawkeye slash clint barton
in the mcu the two characters had
something more closely resembling a
strong friendship either way works here
we're still friends right since they're
not already at me that's first glimpse
in captain america the winter soldier
black widow wears an arrow necklace
although never explained the necklace
points to hawkeye resident archer of the
avengers she can later be seen wearing
the necklace in avengers end game the
easter egg was confirmed in 2021 when
marvel studios honcho kevin feige
confirmed on twitter that the necklace
was a nod to clint feige added that the
jewelry was suggested by black widow
actor scarlett johansson herself yes the
arrow necklace was scarlet's idea she's
been wearing it since captain america
the winter soldier
friends love to share clothes but it
isn't often that you find yourself
sharing an outfit with a raccoon unless
of course you're both guardians of the
galaxy keep an eye on everyone's
favorite interplanetary anti-heroes and
you'll notice that star
peter quill and rocket raccoon share a
scarf between guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 and avengers end game before
star-lord was turned to dust via the
thanos snap in avengers infinity war he
wore a red scarf the only guardians of
the galaxy character to survive the snap
was rocket so it makes for an especially
touching nod when the snarling super
raccoon pops up in avengers end game
wearing the same scarf the scarf
combined with rocket using his most
well-known comic book suit in the big
battle were fun incorporations of comic
book information in the film and we can
only assume that when quill came back
rocket was there to give him a scarf
back and maybe a hug
sometimes the mcu even inserts hints of
other comic book characters into its
costumes in avengers end game for
instance that's a little known reference
to somebody else who briefly became
captain america at least in the comics
when endgame steve goes back in time to
1970 to get the tesseract you can see
that the uniform he's wearing as a
disguise bears last name roscoe this
appears to be a reference to roscoe
simons in mid-70s captain america comics
simons was presented as a youngster who
was a huge fan of cap later captain
america would become nomad leaving his
moniker up for grabs as several
individuals attempted to fill the
position trained by falcon rasco simons
was one of these wannabe warriors
although his story had a sad ending at
the hands of the red skull and it seems
like it's not worth it
and you wonder
why you waited so long for something so
disappointing steve using that name as
his disguise in endgame is a nice nod to
the comic books as well as other people
that have served as captain america but
there is one problem with it the
military lists last names on uniforms
not first names so the reference should
read simon's
while fans may have been too distracted
by an age steve rogers at the end of the
film to pick up on it right away steve
was wearing a recognizable jacket after
going back in the timeline to replace
all the infinity stones it becomes clear
that captain america has altered the
plan where is he
i don't know he blew right by his time
stamp he should be here bucky barnes had
notices that steve is sitting nearby now
an old man having lived the entirety of
a life that had previously been stolen
from the thought out super soldier if
the jacket this old man is wearing looks
familiar that's because it's similar in
color and shape to the jacket he wore in
captain america the first avenger when
audiences first saw him with this look
it was before he became captain america
so it is meant to evoke a return to who
he was in those early scenes bringing
the jacket back in what is perhaps a
final appearance of chris evans cap in
the mcu helps his story come full circle
in black panther the costume department
gave a less than subtle nod to the
pan-african flag went to charles slash
black panther okay and nakia go to south
korea to try and intercept the sale of a
wakandan artifact by ulysses claw the
black market dealer some may recognize
from avengers age of ultron their
outfits stand out the three of them are
in the colors of the pan-african flag
t'challa in black okoye in red and nakia
in green this isn't the only time it
happens either throughout the film
t'challa wears black okoye wears red and
the kia wears green when they're
together and if you watch closely
they're typically lined up to maintain
the message the pan-african flag was
created by marcus garvey a jamaican
journalist and political activist in the
1920s garvey also founded the universal
negro improvement association and the
african communities league the flag is
used as a symbol of black nationalism
and was used as part of the black
liberation movement in the 1960s this
nod to a flag that is so important to
black americans is an excellent touch
eric killmonger stephen
jadaka comes to wakanda where he fights
against t'challa for the wakandan throne
as is his birthright he wins and
t'challa is presumed dead
nah
i'm your king when it's discovered that
t'challa is not dead and the dora
malaysia turns on kill manga he fights
them in a special suit similar to black
panthers a suit he wears has a leopard
prince that was referred to as a golden
jaguar in the comics killmonger has a
favorite pet leopard named prey this cat
is highly trained with more speed and
strength than a typical leopard the suit
may even foreshadow what happens to kill
manga in the film as the pet is also
killed in wakanda
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu easter eggs are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]